(plucky music)
- [Narrator] We visited the Los Angeles
based band La Santa Cecilia
at their concert in New York to talk about
their single, "Winning",
which uses elements
from Bachata as background for a poem
about the evils of social media.
- I wear rainbows as skirts,
two cowboys build a fire,
there's a guy eating a flower--
- Describing "Winning" musically, huh?
- Yeah, it's like a, like a pop-rock,
Bachata, spoken word.
- Punk rock.
- Punky, rocky song.
- So what is Bachata?
- Bachata is a Latin American music genre
from the Dominican republic that is
rising in popularity across the world.
Just look at bachatero Romeo Santos,
the face of Bachata for many.
(singing in foreign language)
He has billions of views on YouTube,
and he's performed a sold
out show to 80,000 fans
at New Jersey's MetLife Stadium.
I have to admit I had never
heard of Bachata before
and especially with the genre's blurring,
it's kind of hard to tell what
exactly is Bachata or not.
Later on I'm going to attempt to create
my own Bachata track, but
first let's break down
the musical DNA of what
makes Bachata, Bachata.
(bachata music)
We interviewed La Santa Cecilia about
how Bachata has inspired them.
This is what they have to say.
- To me Bachata is like, like, a bolero,
and I grew up singing boleros with Pepe,
that's, I mean, that's what we
played when we were younger.
All these beautiful romantic ballads,
and he plays a requinto and,
but it's also very
(speaking foreign language),
it's traditional, right, too so...
- Definitely traditional.
It's like a Caribbean kind of rhythm,
- Yeah, yeah!
I mean, there's a lot of artists like
Juan Luis Guerra who has
been an influence for us,
and it's just like a
danceable kind of rhythm
that we're used to.
- It's music that's played in cantinas
where people are drinking
and feeling things in a very,
like, sensual, sometimes passionate,
very meaningful way,
so, it's like music that
men listen to and cry
and dance, and, you know,
it's kind of one of those kind of
like Bohemia kind of things
that inspires us a lot in the band.
(slow Bachata music) Yeah,
because the, the main feature
on the verses is a spoken word part,
and then, and then if
you're listening carefully,
you'll notice that there's a Bachata
rhythm underneath the verse.
(all laughing)
- Can I borrow those?
Come on, come on!
Maracas.
- Thanks, appreciate it.
- Thanks, baby.
(bright music)
- So where did Bachata come from?
It was born in the Dominican Republic,
and for much of its history,
it wasn't held in such high regard.
In those days, Bachata songs used
acoustic instruments, like this.
(lively singing in foreign language)
From 1930 until 196one
the Dominican Republic
was under the control
of dictator Rafael Trujillo.
During his three decade rule,
Trujillo censored a lot
of the creative arts,
and only sanctioned music was recorded.
During this time, however,
a live music scene flourished,
and this is where Bachata was born.
Within six months of Trujillo's
assassination in 196one
the first Bachata track was recorded
by Jose Manuel Calderon.
These early Bachata songs used equipment
recovered from government radio stations.
Listen to this early track
by Rafael Encarnacion.
(lively singing in foreign language)
This song has a one, six, two,
five, one chord progression
which is a common chord progression
found in Bachata music.
At the time, though, the music wasn't
yet known as Bachata,
instead it was considered
to be a form of bolero,
which is an older, Latin style of music
that has similarities to a jazz ballad.
A defining feature of
this is the bass line
with this type of rhythm.
(bright piano music)
Which emphasizes the, and three, four,
(lively singing in foreign language)
These uniquely Dominican bolero songs
were given the name Bachata
by the upper class to disparage the music.
The word Bachata is Caribbean
Spanish for an informal party.
During this time, Bachata music was often
associated with poverty,
crime, and sensuality,
and found little air time
on the radio or television.
Another ingredient in
Bachata is the rhythm,
commonly known as El
Martillo, or The Hammer.
Commonly played on the Bongos,
it has a lot in common with
the Bongo rhythm of bolero.
Unlike most rhythms, it emphasizes
the four instead of the one.
(bright music)
When Bachata modernized, its guitar solos
began to employ Mambos,
or short, repeating rhythmic melodies.
You can also call them grooves.
Bachata is music intended for dancing.
Where old fashioned Bachatas
were danced more slowly,
the introduction of these Mambos
made it possible for
dancers to enjoy Bolero's
sensual romanticism, and
Meringue's upbeat energy
within the same song.
Listen for the mambos
played by Antony Santos,
a defining figure in the evolution
of modern, electric Bachata.
(bright music)
(lively singing in foreign language)
Another important aspect of modern Bachata
is a rhythmic pattern commonly
played by the lead guitar.
It's arpeggiating triads,
and it goes one, two, three,
one, two, three, two, three.
One, two, three, one,
two, three, two, three.
It's unique because it's dividing
the group of four quarter note beats
into two groups of three eighth notes.
One, two, three, one, two, three.
Plus a group of two eighth notes,
Two, three.
One, two, three, one,
two, three, two, three.
And as you can hear,
it's naturally emphasizing
the fourth beat.
(lively singing in foreign language)
That arpeggiation has become a
signature element in Bachata.
Listen to it in Medicina De
Amor, by Raulin Rodriguez.
(lively singing in foreign language)
In the 1990's, Bachata went
through another big shift.
Aventura, a New York
band led by Romeo Santos,
fused Bachata with Hip Hop, R&B, and Rock,
and even sprinkled
English into the lyrics.
The result was a new
urban style of Bachata.
(lively singing in foreign language)
With Aventura's success,
Bachata became an overnight,
world-wide pop sensation.
The urban style of Bachata,
centered around New York City,
has since dominated over Bachata's
expanding, world-wide audience.
Many fans of Bachata outside
of the Dominican Republic
don't even realize that
other forms of it exist.
So what's next for Bachata?
It's not going to stop
evolving, that's for sure.
Nowadays, artists are recording
bachatas also in English and Italian,
and many are reinterpreting pop songs
from various traditions
with Bachata rhythms
For example, another
bachatero from New York City,
Prince Royce, has a major hit
of a Bachata version of
"Stand By Me" by Ben E. King
♪ When the night has come ♪
Some Bachata fusions
are more experimental.
Let's go back to "Winning",
by La Santa Cecilia.
Upon first listen, it sounds nothing like
the bachatas we've listened to so far.
But it contains many of the
elements that we mentioned.
For example, it has the one, two, three,
one, two, three, two, three
arepeggiated pattern
played by the guitars.
It also has the one six, two,
five, one chord progression
and there's even a bongo
playing a Bachata beat.
♪ No filter, chocolate,
strawberry shakes, follow me ♪
♪ New year send me ♪
(lively singing in foreign language)
♪ GoFundMe, your post has been deleted ♪
♪ #Winning ♪
♪I can find no inspiration,
neverending information ♪
♪ Always stuck in purgatory ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm addicted to your story ♪
In the spirit of fusion
I'm going to remix the song
"Kriye Kriye" into a chiptune track
inspired by retro video game music.
I think a lot of the patterns
and progressions used,
(keyboard notes chiming)
will fit really nicely
with this kind of sound.
(lively retro video game music)
If you liked this episode and want more,
don't forget to subscribe and
hit the notification button.